you may have heard the word Benghazi a
few times or a few thousand times in the
past few years and probes about Benghazi
and Benghazi committee even have had you
been Ghazi situation whether from Fox
News and Republicans in Congress who
exist it's a major scandal or some
liberals joking about it on Twitter it
all has to do with Republicans deeper
beliefs about Barack Obama's presidency
and with the politics surrounding
Hillary Clinton's presidential campaign
but to see how Benghazi fits into all of
that you need to know exactly what
happened in Benghazi in the first place
on the night of September 11th 2012 a
group of Islamist militia members
attacked a US diplomatic outpost in
Benghazi Libya they killed four
Americans including the US ambassador to
Libya Chris Stevens who is visiting from
Tripoli that week the city was a center
of the us-backed rebellion that toppled
Muammar Qaddafi the year before and a
number of armed groups had emerged in
the aftermath it was a dangerous
environment however the u.s. had no
intelligence suggesting a specific
attack was imminent at 9:42 p.m. the
militiamen easily breached the gates of
the compound and set fire to the
building a subsequent State Department
review blamed systemic failures at the
department senior levels for the
missions poor security Stevens had
previously requested more security and
not gotten it in the chaos of the attack
US security officers were separated from
Stevens and shawnsmith another State
Department official the two men died of
smoke inhalation later that night
a team from the nearby CIA annex arrived
and engaged militants before taking
survivors back to the annex a mile away
at 11:15 40 minutes later the attackers
laid siege to the annex as well
the assault resumed around 5:15 a.m.
with two more Americans
security agents Tyrone woods and Glen
Doherty killed by mortars firing on the
annex this later became a big
controversy Republicans accused Obama of
withholding further military support
that might have saved the day but there
were simply no military assets that
could have gotten there in time starting
around 7 a.m. the Americans were able to
escape the compound and leave the
country
the CIA initially blamed the attack on a
mob protesting an anti-islam movie which
had sparked protests elsewhere in the
Middle East then you and Ambassador
Susan Rice made this claim on several
Sunday talk shows it began spontaneously
in Benghazi as a reaction to what had
transpired some hours earlier in Cairo
that turned out to be mostly wrong the
attackers were members of Islamist
militias as we now know not a random mob
Republicans accused the Obama
administration of tampering with
intelligence specifically in Rice's
talking points for the sunday shows to
hide the fact that it was a terrorist
attack did the Obama administration play
down what happened in Libya what
happened in Cairo because it would make
Obama foreign policy look better but
later investigation showed that she'd
honestly repeated CIA analysis rather
than deliberately lying still amidst the
controversy rice withdrew herself from
consideration to become the next
Secretary of State
there have been eight official
investigations into Benghazi mostly
involving are led by congressional
Republicans and none has found any real
evidence of a cover-up or wrongdoing by
the administration with the exception of
the State Department's internal report
blaming its own incompetence for failing
to provide sufficient security so why
Republicans still investigating partly
out of a certainty that something was
wrong stemming from deep-seated
Republican beliefs that Obama is both
weak on terror and corruptly
authoritarian enough to hide the truth
but this is also about politics
Republicans want to embarrass Obama and
damaged Hillary Clinton who is then
Secretary of State at the time of the
attack House Majority Leader Kevin
McCarthy admitted as much on national
television everybody thought Hillary
Clinton was unbeatable right but we put
together a Benghazi special committee a
select committee what are her numbers
today her numbers are dropping why
because she's untrustable and it's kind
of worked the Clinton email scandal rose
from one of the Benghazi investigations
so you can bet we'll be hearing about
Benghazi well into the presidential
election
you
you